und jetzt kommen wir zu unserem cold
case die 19 jährige cornelia geissler
ist leidenschaftliche schwimmerin bis
sie auf dem weg nach hause vergewaltigt
und brutal ermordet wird ihre leiche
entsorgt der täter wie müll im wald 31
jahre ist das jetzt her aber die
ermittler haben die akte noch nicht
geschlossen sie haben sogar einen
verdächtigen im visier und unsere
reporter jan schumann der sich auf
spurensuche begeben
die 19 jährige cornelia geissler lee zur
wendezeit in ilmenau bei erfurt die
junge frau arbeitet in einem
antiquitätengeschäft als verkäuferin
cornelia geht leidenschaftlich gern
schwimmen jeden dienstag trifft sie sich
mit einer freundin in dieser
schwimmhalle doch ihr besuch am 27
november 1990 soll ihr letzter sein
in dieser nacht wird sie vergewaltigt
brutal ermordet ihre leiche im wald
entsorgt
cornelia scheint aber nicht das einzige
opfer des täters zu sein was er mir und
cornelia angetan hat dass es so schlimm
damit zu leben
deswegen mache ich auch therapien und
auch medikamente der hat mein ganzes
leben versaut die bild thüringen
berichtet seit jahren über den fall
mörderjagd nach 30 jahren wird der
mordfall cornelia geißler nach 30 jahren
gelöst polizei ermittelt gegen ihn in
bild spricht er selbst
was mich an diesem fall besonders
schockiert ist dass es mindestens vier
weitere frauen gibt sie vergewaltigt
wurden
[Musik]
ein beschuldigter bestreitet bis heute
die tat doch selbst seine familie glaubt
wegen der indizien und der opfer
aussagen nicht an seine unschuld ich
erlebe es zum ersten mal dass ich eine
komplette familie von einem
familienmitglied zurückzieht weil sie
der meinung ist dass er ein mörder ist
[Musik]
ich finde das sehr schlimm dass der noch
frei herumläuft und ich möchte gern dass
es da irgendwie noch
alle indizien weisen auf ein und
denselben täter hin doch für eine
verurteilung reicht es nicht handelt es
sich um einen serien vergewaltiger wurde
cornelia ermordet weil sie sich gegen
die vergewaltigung gewährt hat bild
reporter jan schumann ist in gotha bei
der kriminalpolizei trifft er den heute
leitenden ermittler jens büchner
[Musik]
wie lief der tag des motors und chrysler
cornelia geißler war am abend des 27
1990 mit einer freundin im hallenbad in
arbeit zum schwimmen vor antreten danach
ist man von der schwimmhalle in richtung
des bahnhofs gegangen dort wohnte diese
freundinnen hat sich getrennt von der
schwimmhalle bis zum haus der freundin
sind sie zu zweit unterwegs dort steigt
cornelia in den bus
für gewöhnlich läuft sie den ganzen weg
nach hause oder zur nahe gelegenen
wohnung ihres freundes nimmt sie heute
den bus weil sie sich bereits verfolgt
fühlt
wir haben den busfahrer als zeugen
vernommen er konnte sich sehr genau an
cornelia geissler erinnern weil ihr
verhalten
insofern etwas ungewöhnlich war weil man
nicht an gemerkt hat dass sie nicht
häufig mit dem bus unterwegs ist sie
hatte probleme den fahrschein zu kaufen
wusste nicht wie teuer die fahrt ist von
daher hat er sich die von ihrer kanzlei
eingeprägt seiner aussage sehr
glaubwürdig und das sollte leider letzte
bus vorbei das ist tatsächlich das
letzte bestätigte lebenszeichen von
cornelia geissler
cornelia steigt im stadtteil perlitz
höhe aus dem bus nur 300 meter von der
wohnung ihrer eltern entfernt
[Musik]
früher anfang der 90er jahre befand sich
die bushaltestelle der stadtlinie dort
auf der gegenüber liegenden seite dort
hat der bus gehalten an der nächsten
haltestelle war cornelia nicht mehr im
bus definitiv sie hat von hier aus noch
ein weg von zirka 300 meter doch zu
hause oder bei ihrem freund der
ebenfalls in der nähe wohnt kommt sie
nie an
[Musik]
die junge frau wird überfallen
vergewaltigt und schließlich ermordet
18 mal sticht der angreifer auf cornelia
ein und lässt ihre leiche einfach in
einem waldstück liegen
einen monat später am silvestertag wird
sie gefunden
wir nähern uns gerade dem fundort der
leiche von cornelia geißler man muss
sich das aber auch vor 30 jahren etwas
anderes vorstellen die kommen gleich auf
höher
und zwar linksseitig hier hinter den
beiden etwas niedrigeren fichten dort
wurde die leiche von einem spaziergänger
gefunden
cornelia geißler war nackt und mit
messerstichen übersät der täter ist
unglaublich brutal vorgegangen die
tatsache dass das junge mädchen
umgebracht wurden sondern dass dir
einfach weggeschmissen wurde nackt
tieren aber ausgesetzt unvorstellbar ich
denke dass so eine geschichte das ist
nicht gut
das muss man sich auch immer wieder so
ein stück weit bewusst machen welche
welche verantwortung wir da in dem fall
haben denn du willst ja den angehörigen
gerecht werden willst ihnen der klarheit
geben cornelia geißler wird am 27
november 1990 in der perle zur höhe in
ilmenau angegriffen und vergewaltigt er
spuren an ihren socken deuten darauf hin
die leiche jedoch in einem nahe
gelegenen wald gefunden
ihre kleidung monate später 20 kilometer
entfernt von einem waldarbeiter bei
neuses
zur zeit der wende bearbeitet eine neue
polizeidirektion den fall waren die
ermittlungen damals unzureichend wurden
parallelen zu weiteren sexualstraftaten
übersehen und warum sind die asservate
heute nicht mehr vorhanden nach heutigen
maßstäben halte ich die ermittlung nicht
für tiefgründig der fall wird 1991
bereits zum cold case keine verdächtigen
keine hinweise durch neue ermittlungen
ändert sich das im jahr 2009 konnten am
leichenfundort mittels eines
metalldetektors ein messer aufgefunden
werden bei dem messer handelt es sich um
ein taschenmesser ein zu ddr-zeiten
handelsübliches objekt es war stark
verwittert stark verrostet das messer
war an einem derart schlechten zustand
dass wir es nicht eindeutig als
tatmittel identifizieren konnten
ein rückschlag erst 2018 gibt es einen
durchbruch in den ermittlungen
im juli des jahres 2018 meldete sich
eine zeugin
eigeninitiativ und machte angaben die
neuen schwung in die ermittlungen
brachten durch einen tv bericht wird
nicole z auf den fall aufmerksam
vor 30 jahren wurde auch die gelernte
elektromonteur in in ilmenau
vergewaltigt sie glaubt es handelt sich
um denselben täter macht wichtige
angaben
der kripo noch mal gemeldet
ganz viele jahre danach können sie mir
erzählen wie es dazu kam halte mich hat
das dann ganze zeit beschäftigt und dann
kam ich irgendwann abends zum entschluss
dort bei der kripo anzurufen und ich
wollte auch gerne das cornelias mutter
gewissheit hat wer cornelia umgebracht
hat wo haben sie die kraft plötzlich her
genommen
ich wollte gerne gerechtigkeit
auch nicole wird 1990 vergewaltigt der
täter kommt aus einem haus in
bahnhofsnähe und verwickelte sie in ein
gespräch
drängt darauf sie nach hause zu bringen
und auf einmal hat er mich dann an der
tür gedrückt
das war so eine holztür ich konnte auch
nicht mehr fliegen und so und ich hab
dann reizgas rausgeholt aus meiner jeans
jacke
und habe da schon drauf gedrückt aber es
irgendwie misslungen und da ist das
reizgas zu boden gefallen dann hat auf
einmal besser rausgehalten hat mir am
hals gehalten er hat dann gesagt
vergewaltigen und danach bringt er mich
um also ich hatte
todesangst und habe mich noch ein
schuldig wegen den reizgas und dann
hat er mich
noch weiter im keller ein gefährt das
da waren so zwei keller buchten und zwar
ziemlich eng drin gewesen und dann hat
er
seine jacke und noch fußboden hingelegt
und ich sollte mich da hinlegen und
meine kleidung musste ich ausziehen und
dann hat er sich auf mich gelegt
und ist in mir eingedrungen und
hat sich an mich befriedigt
das ist so als etwas erst gestern
passiert ist
das ist ganz schlimm also mit sowas zu
leben müssen
aufgrund ihrer angaben gerät ein heute
79 jähriger ins visier der ermittler
nach aufrufen der polizei melden sich
weitere frauen gegenüber bild streitet
wolf hat den mord an cornelia ab aber
das mädchen nicht ermordet sogar meine
frau glaubt dass sich der mörder
[Musik]
sie ist ausgezogen und wohnt bei unserem
sohn michael
dabei hätten wir haben 18 september
goldene hochzeit gefeiert
das wurde jetzt wieder abgesagt
sie können da zum wahrscheinlichen täter
recht detaillierte angaben machen so
dass wir diese person identifizieren
konnten und als beschuldigten nun in
unserer ermittlungsverfahren wo führen
konnten sie nennen ihn beschuldigten
können sie uns sagen was das für den
frei bedeutet zum beschuldigten wird man
wenn tatsächliche anhaltspunkte
vorliegen dass man täter einer straftat
ist das können sowohl spuren dna
fingerabdrücke sein oder aber auch
zeugenaussagen wurde cornelia opfer
eines serientäters ihre kleidungsstücke
und damit mögliche dna spuren gibt es
nicht mehr kann der markt nach über 30
jahren trotzdem noch aufgeklärt werden
die asservate von damals existieren
nicht mehr aber die aussage eines
vergewaltigungs opfers führt nach 30
jahren zu einem beschuldigten des
körpers im jahr 2020 bereits jahren im
haus das beschuldigt das amtsgericht
erfurt hat auf antrag der
staatsanwaltschaft erfurt für das
wohnhaus des beschuldigten einen
durchsuchungsbeschluss erlassen wir
konnten allerdings keine weiß
erheblichen gegenstände im haus des
beschuldigten sicherstellen der
beschuldigte machte auf uns
immer einen sicheren und selbstbewussten
eindruck ich persönlich gehe davon aus
dass er der meinung war
keine spuren hinterlassen zu haben schon
gar nicht nach der langen zeit der
beschuldigte war auch schon in der ddr
straffällig geworden er wurde zu einer
mehrjährigen haftstrafe wegen eines
körperverletzungsdelikts verurteilt die
ja auch abgesessen hat
dass der mordfall cornelia geißler noch
gelöst wird hofft auch
vergewaltigungsopfer nicole z heute
mutter einer elfjährigen tochter
[Musik]
da geht es mir eiskalt den rücken runter
und manchmal kann ich abends nicht
richtig einschlafen wenn alles ruhig ist
so still ist da kommt manchmal auch die
angst durch was er mir und cornelia
angetan hat dass es so schlimm damit zu
leben deswegen mache ich auch therapien
und auch medikamente
hat mein ganzes leben versaut doch ohne
geständnis oder weitere beweise liegt
der fall auf eis und der beschuldigte
bleibt frei warum gab es bisher kein
urteil
wir haben keine objektiven beweise in
dieser sache wir verfügen über eine
indizienkette die aber nicht ausreichend
ist um eine anklage tatsächlich
begründen zu können ich kann aber die
entscheidungsfindung der
staatsanwaltschaft nachvollziehen
obgleich wir natürlich alle uns wünschen
dass es hier zu einem urteil kommen
würde wir müssen das aushalten
die polizei sucht weitere opfer denen
1989 bis 1991 in ilmenau ähnliches
passiert ist gesucht wird ein täter mit
blonden kurzen haaren ohne bart der
frauen im bereich des bahnhofs
angesprochen hat die polizei will wissen
wer hat ein solches messer besessen und
bei wem war es ende 1990 nicht mehr
vorhanden und wer hat am 27 november
1990 im wohngebiet politzer höhe in der
heinrich-hertz-straße etwas
ungewöhnliches gesehen oder gehört wer
hat vom 27 november bis 31 dezember 1990
beobachtungen am fundort der leiche im
bereich der heutigen autobahnausfahrt
ilmenau ost gemacht
oder im bereich von neuses wo cornelias
kleidung gefunden wurde
[Musik]
wir haben die hoffnung noch nicht
aufgegeben dass es eventuell mit wir so
gibt die sich bisher aufgrund von
bestehenden
abhängigkeitsverhältnissen noch nicht
bei der polizei gemeldet haben ich bitte
sie melden sie sich bei uns was ist ihr
wunsch an die menschen da draußen
vielleicht sogar weitere opfer sie
brauchen sich nicht zu schämen sondern
die täter sollten sich schämen was sie
gemacht haben und dass sie opfer zur
polizei gehen sollen und und ich möchte
gern dass es da irgendwie noch beweise
gibt
für nicole und die anderen opfer ist das
der einzige weg vergeltung zu erfahren
denn die vergewaltigungen sind
mittlerweile verjährt aber
mord verjährt nie
ja seit 31 jahren hofft die familie
darauf endlich zu erfahren wie ihre
tochter ermordet hat